another school shooting another
Community terrorized at Covenant School
in Nashville shots fired gunning down
three children and three adult staffers
there were so many police cars and then
the ambulances started
getting away from the school
and that's when I had heard it was a
school
shooting minutes later in a school Lobby
two arriving officers fire back the
officers engaged her
she was fatally shot by responding
police officers investigators were left
probing the car of the shooter a 28 year
old identified as Audrey Elizabeth Hale
and what drove hail to open fire on
children I was literally moved to tears
to see this and the kids as they were
being ushered out of the
building there was a door that was
entered all doors were locked to our
understanding and how exactly she got in
at this point it's still under
investigation the daughter of one
Covenant teacher was texting with her
mother who said she was hiding with
students in a closet and hearing
gunshots close by it's disgusting and I
yeah I just I have no words like I'm
just trying to process it all it's so
terrible so sad from President Joe Biden
there was more consolation with little
hope of action it's just a sick you know
we're still Gathering the facts of what
happened and why police say the attacker
a former student was armed with a pistol
and two assault rifles the style of
weapon the U.S Congress banned in 1994
before allowing the ban to expire 10
years later Biden again called for
Congress to renew the ban we have
to do more to stop gun violence it's
ripping our communities apart ripping a
soul this nation but on a divided
Capitol Hill he has no real chance of
passing it or ending the decades-long
series of mass shootings in America John
hendren Al Jazeera